the World Cup began with a spectacular
opening ceremony in the Persian Gulf
nation of Qatar over the weekend Team
USA kicks off its first appearance in
the tournament since 2014 later today I
think the game starts at two or the
match starts at two but another American
who qualified for the competition is
also grabbing headlines and she is
making history Nikki Batiste is here now
with her story Nikki good morning can't
wait to meet her she's amazing good
morning everyone she is one of the first
Americans selected for the World Cup who
actually wears a different uniform Katie
Nesbitt is the first American woman to
officiate at a men's World Cup it's a
role she has spent a lifetime preparing
for in some unexpected ways
[Music]
this is your office yeah this is it
welcome
sprinting alongside men in Major League
Soccer is a woman just as fast referee
Katie Nesbitt how many miles do you run
during a game like three to four miles
and there are no subs for you guys
that's right watch my colleague Kenton
racing to keep up with the League's 2020
assistant referee of the Year assistant
referees used to be called lines men as
in man sure yeah and in that smile you
can see Nesbit as one of the women
changing the game the assistant referee
who keeps an eye out for offsides made
it all the way to the World Cup when did
you find out just on Twitter when you
saw your name there what was your
reaction honestly this felt like
something impossible that could never
happen so it was the most unreal feeling
each game every official is evaluated
and Nesbit got picked as one of just six
women who for the first time are joining
more than 100 male officials at the
World Cup such an honor that I get to do
this and to represent female referees in
this way and to represent my country in
this way the 34 year old who already
left at the 2019 Women's World Cup and
men's league championships here in the
U.S spent decades preparing for the
world stage I got involved just by
helping out at my brother's soccer games
and eventually kind of made it into
something I could make money doing so
when you were 14 in a refereeing
did you ever think for a minute this
could ever become a career not at all
everybody asked why I stuck with it and
I'm still not really sure sometimes
Nesbit stuck with it even while
competing as a figure skater and then
trying a different experiment I started
liking chemistry when I was in high
school and my my high school teacher
blew something up and I was like well
this could work for me so Nesbitt earned
a PhD studying the brain chemistry of
traumatically injured patients and
became a chemistry professor at
Maryland's Towson University I had two
computers set up in my office one so I
could analyze my data and the other one
so I could have every single World Cup
game on is Katie Nesbitt the chemist and
Katie knows but the referee yeah most
people are going to say what I mean
they're just two passions of mine they
were both things that I love to do so I
pushed the limits as much as I could in
both areas but pushing the limits in
soccer soon meant changing her field
full time to pursue refereeing I was at
a very high level in in both areas and
was really feeling the strain of not
being able to put my best foot forward
in one or the other
women have held the whistle in major
men's sports for a while Violet Palmer
became the first woman to ref an NBA
game a quarter century ago and earlier
this year Sarah Thomas Made Super Bowl
history but Nesbit says she didn't want
to stand out
I chose to wear my hair in a bun and not
in a ponytail because I wanted to be
seen as just the same as every other
referee though she admits that didn't
always happen have you ever faced sexism
yeah of course there have been
everything from looks to comments made
to me how has that felt it was difficult
in the moment of course but it kind of
also fuels your fire a little bit too
watch me yeah exactly see you at the
World Cup in 2022. I can honestly say I
am living my dream and this was the
biggest dream come true for me so
honestly I'm just enjoying it right now
and at the World Cup There are rules for
the refs too Nesbit isn't allowed to
officiate any games in the group with
Team USA and she only finds out which
game she's working a day or two in
advance to avoid even the appearance of
favoritism something we didn't get into
in the piece too much is just how
physically fit she has to be she tells
this great story of running along the
sideline with a male player and he's
looking at her to see if she can keep up
she does yeah I don't know if Ken can I
think it's next to him
clearly she's athletic yeah well and
it's interesting for the World Cup she
has to pass the same physical assessment
physical test as all the male referees
of course of course yeah I love the
combination of Nikki of her two passions
chemistry and and the World Cup and it's
so nice when you can say this that she's
living her dream that her dream comes
true yeah she's so inspiring and she's
worked so hard for this and it's such a
great representation of what women can
do on a male dominated world that's so
much pressure she's just a wonderful
woman I can
so much